Oh Jeremy Hunt is still in the race bird
number 10 and his campaign chairman Sir
Patrick McLaughlin joins us now from
Derbyshire thank you very much for being
in the program this morning before the
break we heard from Boris Johnson do you
think he would make a good Prime
Minister well I think the person who
will make the best Prime Minister is
Jeremy Hunt and that's why I'm
supporting Jeremy hunt if Boris wins I
will support Boris in the very difficult
job that he will have addressing the
country's issues and not least those is
ensuring that we leave the European
Union as quickly as possible and
preferably by the 31st of October in the
interview with Boris Johnson he spoke
about their deep feeling language he
feels over the case of NASA Navin in
Zachary Ratcliffe but he said that Iran
is responsible do you think he's right
there well he is right in obviously Iran
is responsible for holding somebody in
their jails and somebody that should be
released as soon as possible and I think
everybody has got a great sympathy with
her family I think perhaps some of the
language that Boris has used as not
helped the case I also decided an
interview to really kind of focus on
some of the policy issues rather than
Boris Johnson's private life but it
feels as if he's struggling to escape
that there's more revelations in the
Sunday Times today do you think the boss
Johnson's private life is in issue or do
you think that actually he's well within
his rights to say that this is a matter
disturb his private life it's not not
something he's he's he's well within the
rights to say his private life is his
private life and that is the case and
what we've got to do in this campaign
and what Jeremy Hunt is doing is
focusing very much on the issues so
while I was very disappointed about with
Boris in his final response to you he
would not agree to do a face-to-face
debate with Jeremy before the ballot
papers go out it's all very well doing
one-to-one interviews and you did give
him a very tough interview but really we
do need to see face-to-face interviews
between the two main candidates that are
standing to be the leader of the
Conservative Party and by that very
nature the next prime minister of this
country and of course that invitation
still open for Boris Johnson if he does
want to come
and be quizzed by Kay Burleigh next week
now is not just and I'm not just it
shouldn't just be on one TV channel it
should be a few he's he's agreeing to do
them after the ballot papers have gone
out that's too late
you should do them this week before the
ballot papers go out now in the
interview also last boss Johnson if he's
trying to have his cake and eat it when
it comes to his spending plans but I
have to say Jeremy Hunt spending plans
on exactly and you know totally totaling
up are they the Institute for Fiscal
Studies says that actually what mr.
hunters promised is actually more
expensive than what mr. Johnson has
promised costing up to sixty five
billion pounds I mean he's trying to
have an even bigger cake and eat it here
isn't he what Jeremy is doing is setting
out the plans that he would want to
implement over his period of prime
minister it's not all saying that it's
kind of happening day one but what is
vitally important is that we attract
more businesses to this country we
create a culture of wanting to invest
Jeremy has the advantage of somebody who
set up a business employed two hundred
people by the time the business was sold
on that that was a huge achievement and
he knows what it what businesses what
entrepreneurs need we can spend more
money when we earn more money and that's
the important the important point a good
health service realized I'm a good
economy a good education service relies
on strong and good economy to spend that
money we've got to earn it well if
Jeremy Hunt is the entrepreneur that you
say then surely he will be quite
concerned by these quotes from the
Institute for Fiscal Studies saying that
his policies would amplify the long-run
challenges faced in the UK public
finances and wouldn't leave any scope to
relieve the pressure on other spending
departments without tax risers all
morning and I think you can see from
what jeremy has done since he's been in
the cabinet he's been in the cabinet now
for nine years and in the department
he's were he's worked in he's looked for
savings where those savings were to be
made but he also left the Health Service
having secured the largest biggest
investment in the health service we've
seen for many a year some twenty billion
pounds extra on top was on top of what
was already planned so
is somebody who says you know doing the
job of prime minister of this country is
about there's two ends to it there is of
course the economy but there is also the
public services that people want expect
and demand and just finally your former
concept or Party Chairman so you know
the membership in the grassroots pretty
well do you really think they're going
to pick Jeremy Hunt to be the next prime
minister I've always taken the view that
you never quite know the results of an
election until you hear them and I think
there is every chance I think Jeremy is
picking up a lot of support in the
country you if you look at these
hustings people going in so saying
they're skeptical coming out saying that
they're gonna back Jeremy Hunt because
they were impressed with the way in
which he answered the questions and if
Boris is so far out in front I come up
with this again do a public debate with
Jeremy before the ballot papers go out